the Harry Potter world may seem like a
wondrous place filled with magic butter
beer and chocolate frogs but there are
still some pretty dark and twisted parts
of the stories the series may have been
kid-friendly at first but it quickly did
away with any age constraints to cast
its spell on generations thanks in part
to some surprisingly grown-up elements
from suggestive names to infuriating
character choices here are some aspects
of the Harry Potter series that take on
a whole new meaning for adult audiences
negligence or abuse Dumbledore does a
great job of passing himself off as a
kindly benevolent father figure to Harry
and the rest of the student body but if
you take a close look at his actual
actions he's a pretty icy person who
knowingly sends children into harm's way
for the sake of an obscure prophecy and
his willingness to throw Harry to the
wolves sometimes literally speaking is
just part of the series troubling trend
of adults being negligent or even
possibly abusive to these kids Hagrid
regularly writes out roadmaps for the
main trio to waltz into danger I shoulda
said that I should not have said that
the faculty is filled with crazy people
and even the parents are pretty lousy
how else could you explain Hermione's
folks who are muggles allowing their
eleven-year-old to run through a wall
and hop on a train they never even saw
or how no one bothered to check on baby
Harry Potter for a decade after he was
dropped off at the doorstep of an ant
knuckle everyone knew were terrible good
adulting everybody the Ministry of what
there are tons of pseudo political
commentaries contained in the Harry
Potter series
Gellert Grindelwald tries to enslave the
muggle population by way of a global
Wizarding war that not coincidentally
rages alongside the real-life events of
world war ii balda Mort and his Death
Eaters fight for genetic supremacy over
half-bloods and muggles like some of the
worst villains in history but perhaps
the most unsettling aspect of the
stories is that the Ministry of Magic
remains in place without any checks or
balances and seems to impress certain
classes of wizards they have a
totalitarian approach to justice with
boundary free surveillance options at
their disposal and
may have soul-sucking Dementors who
inflict cruel punishment on prisoners
they're also in charge of all the money
and sometimes distribute assets unfairly
between various families it just goes to
show that even at its best the wizarding
world is never truly free
just ask the house elves fat shaming it
gets a laugh out of a lot of readers but
the way JK Rowling writes about Dudley
Dursley in the earliest installments of
the Harry Potter series is kind of
troubling although she has plenty of
faults to choose from while writing
about Harry spoiled cousin she pays a
lot of attention to the fact that he's
portly or as she writes it the size of a
young killer whale descriptions of
Dudley's pigley little eyes and his
resemblance to a pig in a wig read has
especially cruel and unnecessary in
retrospect even if Rowling has insisted
she's against fat shaming the sexual
innuendos the Harry Potter books may be
meant for kids but certain parts belong
in the restricted section for example
there is the in Gore geo spell which
seems like a poor choice of name on
Rowling's Park and is probably the only
explanation for how Hagrid's father made
whoopee with a giantess I shoulda said
that I should not have said that then
there's the fact that these are all
teenage students who've had no sex ed
coursework at all
some have traced the timing of
Nymphadora Tonks conception to her
parents teen years Rowling herself has
said she didn't mean to encourage teen
pregnancy in the story but thanks to a
dirty Easter egg in the marauders map
from the Prisoner of Azkaban movie we
know Hogwarts could get pretty steamy
with or without proper education about
safe sex wasted gifts as creative and
thorough as Rowling was when creating
the Potter verse there are some aspects
of the stories that become pretty
frustrating in hindsight Snape as the
gift of legitimacy for example but
doesn't bother using it to figure out
that Barty Crouch jr. is drinking
Polyjuice potion to disguise himself as
mad-eye moody in the Goblet of Fire
seems like that might have been
important
[Music]
and Hermione's time-turner a literal
time travel device could have been used
for far more important things than
overloading her school schedule and
springing an animal from execution Harry
could have probably used that luck
potion he gets in half-blood Prince to
help him defeat Voldemort and Minerva
McGonagall shape-shifting skills should
have given her an upper hand in
undermining Dolores Umbridge who just so
happens to be a sucker for cats and the
consequences may be severe instead all
of these elements just come and go as
trivial moments of convenience despite
the fact that there is an all-out war in
motion and let's not forget how casually
Dumbledore gifts Harry one of the three
sacred Deathly Hallows the cloak of
invisibility long before he could come
anywhere near appreciating its true
value perverted poltergeist Harry Potter
fans might be inclined to feel sorry for
Moaning Myrtle since she's obviously a
sensitive person who didn't deserve to
die at such a young age but that doesn't
excuse her posthumous perversions in the
Goblet of Fire she has a habit of
sneaking in on boys in the bathtub and
spying on them without their permission
stoner house house
hufflepuff boasted some of the nicest
and most serene students of the hogwarts
bunch and there may have been a reason
for the relaxed attitudes not only does
the name of their house sound kind of
like it endorses huffing and puffing but
Hufflepuff stated to excel in herbology
love to laugh and lived right by the
kitchens coincidence Weasley weirdos in
the Prisoner of Azkaban the Dark Lord's
snivelling sidekick Peter Pettigrew is
eventually spotted alive and well on the
marauders map that Fred and George
Weasley have been holding on to that's
how he's ultimately discovered to be
disguised as Ronald's pet rat but if
he's always visible on the map and the
Weasley twins have full access to it and
in theory would check in on their
younger brother once in a while they
have to know he has unexpected company
in his room each
and just ignore it you don't need magic
powers to see that's pretty messed up
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]